-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
of The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about
to play a game of "Catchphrase,"
but we need some partners.
Joining my team
is one of the greatest
tennis players of all time.
Give it up for Serena Williams!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on!
That's exactly right!
A standing ovation!
Come on.
You didn't even do anything.
-Oh!
-You just walked out.
They love you that much.
Come on, that's --
that's exactly right.
Come on.
That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
We love you.
[ Drumroll ]
You better stay standing.
Tariq, your partner
stars in the number-one movie
in the country right now,
"Barbarian" --
please welcome Justin Long!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Standing ovation.
-Hi.
-You got a standing ovation.
-No, they were already standing.
They were already standing.
I'll take it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
Enjoy, everybody.
Here's how the game works.
I'm gonna start the round by
pressing start on this buzzer.
And, Justin, you will draw
a clue from the top of the pile.
-Okay.
-You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer
to the person on your right.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We're gonna play three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
-Mm, okay.
-Serena, you're over there.
Justin, right?
-Yeah.
-You're there?
Sorry.
-Justin, it's you and I.
-Yeah.
-There's no one else even here.
Just you and I here.
-I wish this were a beard off.
[ Light laughter ]
Then we'd have it in the bag.
-We are --
We're in the zone right now.
We're in the zone.
-We're in the zone.
We got this.
-Not here.
-Yes.
-Here we go.
-I have utmost respect for you,
but not here.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Wow, wow, here we go!
-Anywhere.
-And go.
[ Beeping ]
-Um, a type of fancy latte.
"I want a this latte."
-A chai latte.
-Yes, but this --
a holiday season,
around Halloween.
-A pumpkin spice latte.
-Yep, yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's me. Oh, sorry.
Uh, uh, uh, okay.
It's a vacuum that's a robot.
-Hoover.
Um, oh, God.
I don't know.
That thing.
-Yes, yes!
-That thing -- the round thing.
-Yes!
-That.
I don't know.
I don't use that.
-Rhymes with something
you sweep with.
-Uh, I don't know, sweep.
-What do you sweep with?
-Jeep.
-Not -- no.
What do you sweep with?
-A broom.
-It's kinda like --
-I don't know.
I have --
I have central vacuuming.
-But, it's a -- it's a one --
-I know what
you're talking about,
but I don't know the name.
-It's a one blank apartment.
It's a one --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
I have central vacuuming.
-So close.
Close, close.
-What do you mean
you don't know?!
-I don't wanna say why.
-You don't know Roomba?
-Roomba.
-You gotta get a Roomba!
-I don't know that!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, now -- now everyone does.
What a great ad.
-It is a good ad for Roomba,
yeah.
-We're good, still good.
-Gosh.
-You should get a free Roomba.
-That was -- that was rough.
I would have never gotten that.
-Yeah, but I think eventually
you were getting
closer and closer.
-Rhymes with Zumba.
-Yeah, there you go, thank you.
-I mean, I don't know.
-I still wouldn't have got it.
-I don't think you can say --
Rhymes with "croomba."
[ Laughter ]
What, are you Dr. Seuss?
All right, here we go.
I'm gonna start off this one.
Here we go.
And start.
All right, we got this.
[ Beeping ]
Okay.
Pfft!
It's a game with X's and O's.
-Come on.
-It's a game with --
-Oh, Tic-Tac-Toe.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a character --
a girl who's also part fish.
-A mermaid.
Uh, "Splash."
-The full name is...?
-Um, a mermaid.
Oh, "Little Mermaid."
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whew!
-Okay.
Um, when you're playing tennis
and the score is even,
and it's not --
it's 40-all, it is...
-40-love.
-If it's 40-40, it is...
-Deuce.
-Yes.
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, it's a --
it's a type of thing
when you try
to get a big choice.
It's a big choice.
And you move the things,
and you put the quarter in,
and you get --
and the thing goes down --
-Oh, is it the...
[ Buzzer]
...a claw machine?
Oh!
-No, no!
-Come on, come on!
-[ Laughing ]
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you, yes.
-All right, let's play the --
the third round.
Here we go.
This round is worth
10,000 points.
-Whoa.
-So it's anyone's game.
Let's do this.
-We got this.
-This is it. Come on.
-Come on.
-Okay, okay.
-We were doing good.
We were doing good.
-We're perfect, yes.
-Do I go again?
Okay.
All right, Tariq, we got this.
-Ready.
[ Beeping ]
Okay. Oh
"Snap into a --"
-A Slim Jim.
-Yes.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A type of, uh...
a barn --
-Barn door.
-Yeah, but it's a --
It's --
-It's a house?
-Blank Queen, song, by ABBA.
-I don't know ABBA like that.
-Yeah, you do.
[ Laughter ]
Like, if you go to a club,
you --
if you go to a club, you --
-"Dancing Queen."
-Yes, and then this is --
-♪ Dancing, dancing ♪
-This a type --
a type of barn dance.
Oh!
-A barn -- dance?
A barn dance.
-But it's not a -- it's not a --
It's not a triangle,
not a circle, but a --
-It's a square --
A square dance!
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, no!
-A shirt that comes
all the way up to here.
-A collar -- a big collar --
a turtleneck.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Um, French eat this bread, it's
a long piece of bread in France.
-Baguette, baguette!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-As a kid, Tariq,
who loves this type of food
that you put butter on?
-Toast.
-No, no, you go --
[ Buzzer ]
-Corn, corn!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-What do you mean?
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
-Go to the tape!
Our thanks to Serena Williams,
the champ!
-Yeah!
-Justin Long, Tariq Trotter.
We're talking to Serena
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.